nous allons constituer des stocks les
deschiens mayday mayday quiconque reçoit
ce message je suis le docteur la chatte
moi et mes amis ici présents venant de
la forêt joly qui a été détruite dans
des circonstances mal en contre
s'il vous plaît oui bordeaux
donc depuis nous irons dans l'espace en
quête d'une maison
nous n'avons pas de système de
propulsion et notre intelligence
artificielle a besoin d'une sérieuse
mise à jour ordinateur que le lock-out
habitable la plus proche
connue mais ça c'est pas le pire parce
que pour couronner le tout selon mes
calculs il ne nous reste plus que deux
mois d'oxygène de tampon c'est donc pour
cette raison que nous nous en remettons
à vous oui vous qui que vous soyez
derrière cet écran pour pouvoir espérer
continuer de vivre avec vous le folle
aventure à la fois éducative mais aussi
amusante
il nous faut des sous l'univers est
vaste avec ses mystères à percer ses
aventures qui nous attendent mais ses
aventures elles n'existeront que si vous
êtes là que si vous répondez à ce
message
alors je vous sens
du fond de mon coeur est dénommée gros
costaud merde tu fait pourquoi je suis
le docteur la chatte selon mes calculs
il nous reste maintenant un mois
d'oxygène
aidez nous je vous en prie non mais des
onze je pouvais pas savoir que c'est une
mauvaise approche propre nom mais pas
obligé parce que moi je n'ai jamais été
dans l'espace surcroît passion pour
l'espace
désolé mais s'étaient quittés classe des
thérapies plus beau jeu ce n'est pas bon